have you ever tried to imagine what the
world was like in the distant past
maybe you'd like to explore the age of
the dinosaurs when the earth was much
hotter than it was today
perhaps you'd prefer when temperatures
drop too much colder than today
you could track a mammoth alongside our
early ancestors who evolved around the
end of the last ice age
we know about all of these ancient
climate trends because scientists
learned how to estimate them using
evidence from ice cores tree rings and
other natural phenomena
we now know that for most of human
history people could expect a pattern
that looks something like this graph
from the national aeronautics and space
administration which shows how
temperatures changed each year in
comparison to this line which represents
the average global annual temperature
from 1880 to 1899.
when we look at the time period between
1880 and 1940 we can see that some years
temperatures would be higher than this
average some years they would be lower
but they generally swing back to a
pretty comfortable state
around the 1950s though the global
average temperature began to climb to
unprecedented levels our ancient
temperature records never showed such a
sudden increase
when we look at the time period from
1950 to today we can see that while
temperatures still swing back down some
years these colder years are still much
hotter than the average temperatures in
the past
researchers noticed a change in the
concentration of greenhouse gases in the
earth's atmosphere these greenhouse
gases trap heat from the sun in our
atmosphere similar to how a greenhouse
allows sunlight to pass through its
glass walls but prevents the heat it
creates from leaving this greenhouse
effect is what keeps our planet warm and
habitable enough for life however the
amount of one particular greenhouse gas
was rising carbon dioxide or co2 co2 is
naturally one of the most notable
greenhouse gases besides water vapor but
we can also release co2 by burning wood
or fossil fuels like coal and oil
over time humans have increasingly
relied on these fuels to power things
like planes cars and trains as well as
to generate electricity as a result of
these human activities more co2 is being
released into the atmosphere than ever
before much more than is normally
released by the earth and at a much
faster rate the increasingly heavy
blanket of greenhouse gases is trapping
excess heat in our atmosphere rather
than allowing more of it to radiate into
space as normal this is what's causing
earth's average temperature to rise
beyond what scientists would expect
based on historical patterns
while scientists once referred to this
process as global warming most now
prefer the more general term climate
change
a world that's a little bit warmer on
average might not seem like such a big
deal but we've learned that even a small
shift in the planet's natural processes
can have drastic consequences
when studying the early signs of climate
change scientists predicted that as cold
places like the north and south pole got
warmer the ice would begin to melt
all of that frozen water suddenly
flowing into the oceans would cause sea
levels to rise which would affect the
planet's weather system
have you heard all the news about weird
weather in the past few years
snow in places that's usually warm and
dry or drought in places that are
usually cold and rainy
huge fires during extremely hot summers
severe storms battering coastlines and
flooding cities
many of these natural hazards used to be
somewhat rare but now they're becoming
more common exactly as climate
scientists predicted
people have relied on relatively
consistent weather patterns for
generations so they aren't prepared to
adapt to these changes in their local
environment communities that are already
feeling the effects of climate change
are worried that they're going to lose
their homes their livelihoods or their
sources of food and water
scientists are working on technologies
that can help us remove some of the
excess co2 from the atmosphere but in
the meantime they recommend that we emit
less co2 in the first place this would
allow us to limit how much the global
average temperature increases giving
communities time to adapt to changes in
their surroundings
of course it's complicated to change the
way our societies work to help reduce
co2 emissions you may see some people
advocating for tweaking individual
behaviors like eating plant-based diets
or using low-carbon transportation
methods
you may see others saying that since
large organizations and highly populated
countries emit the most co2 we need to
push them to make more wide-ranging
institutional changes
as someone who works in environmental
science i know that sorting through all
of these different facts and opinions on
climate change can be overwhelming
it's difficult to think about living in
a world that may be very different from
what i've always known in the past
i've found it helpful to both adopt
simple sustainable habits in my own life
while also seeking out community groups
that work on bigger initiatives it's
easier to imagine the future when you
help others to shape it
now that we've taken some time to think
about earth's past and what's happening
to it in the present try looking towards
the future of our planet what is your
ideal future and how can you help to
make it happen